here's your chance to put your questions
to our bear fair who has awarded the
nobel prize in physics for the discovery
of giant magneto resistance or gmr the
discovery has touched millions of lives
all over the world gmr led to the
technology that allows us to store huge
amounts of data on tiny high-tech
devices so if you've ever wondered about
the science behind computer memories or
mp3 players now's your chance to ask
your questions directly to professor
fair to upload your questions on nobel
prize orgs youtube channel simply click
on post a video response and please be
sure to upload your questions no later
than the 19th of March 2010 we're
looking forward to hearing from you